Unless you're living in a cave and your
only source of news is visual politic,
in which case thank you very much.
You probably realize that Fidel Castro
died,
ends with his death.
A communist icon disappears.
Fidel Castro ruled over Cuba with an
iron fist for over 50 years.
Now,
many people,
ones where the Fidelis death will be the
first step in a transition for Cuba,
a transition from a communist
dictatorship to a liberal democracy.
The reality is is that Fidel Castro,
he retired from politics in 2008,
handing over power to his brother Raul
Castro,
keeping Cuba really in the family
business.
The truth is that Raul found himself
having to apply several reforms in Cuba.
Reforms that it's not such a long time
ago would have been impossible to
imagine in a regime that touted itself
as the perfect communist system.
Castro ism is done,
at least the way we know it.
No one really knows what will become of
Cuba,
but one thing is the absolute certain.
It's changing.
Well.
You will ask for a video about Cuba and
you know that here,
a visual politic.
We do like to think outside of the box,
so in this video we're answering a very
important question that we don't believe
has been answered yet.
Is now a good time to invest in Cuba?
Is it possible to make money out of the
political changes that are expected on
the island today?
We're going to answer that question.
History shows us that when an economy
goes from a plan's one to a free market,
one,
there is a window of time where it's
possible to make a fortune.
A good example of this is the Czech
Republic,
particularly the city of Prague.
Well,
I'm making this video.
I am British,
but I live in Prague now.
At the beginning of the 19 nineties,
the Czech Republic was opening up its
economy for the first time after decades
of communism.
This means that for the first time in
years you could buy and sell houses.
Not only that,
since the country was relatively poor,
the price of property,
it was very low.
This attracted a lot of foreign
investors,
particularly from the north of Italy.
They were buying property for almost no
money at all.
Then years later,
the Czech economy started growing fast.
Foreign companies came and settled down
here.
Tourism grew and local people started
companies in a short time,
the price of houses doubled and those
people have invested early,
became a millionaire.
Very
similar thing might just happened in
Cuba,
but hold on just a second because this
isn't quite as simple as it sounds.
Other former communist countries like
the Ukraine didn't have the same amount
of luck,
ends more than one investor who invested
in post-communist.
Ukraine has gone bankrupt before.
Considering investing in Cuba,
it's important to understand what's
going on in the country,
what is the nature of the reforms that
are taking place.
But before we get into all of that,
let's take a look.
Tuition in Cuba today,
Cuba is a communist country.
This means that their whole economy is
directed by the government for some
clarity in the good times,
the Cuban government employees at 92
percent of the country's people.
This means that almost everyone was
working in the public sector,
but those were the 19 eighties when Cuba
exported sugar,
tobacco and all sorts of fruit to the
Soviet Union was in 1989.
The Berlin Wall came down and Fidel
Castro lost his trading
absolutely
the US embargo,
which forbids American companies from
doing any kind of business with the
islands and Cuba was practically
isolated from the rest of the world.
This resulted in a brutal economic
crisis that lasted until the year 2000.
This was when Hugo Chavez came to power
in Venezuela.
As you can see in another one of our
videos,
Venezuela used to be a very oil rich
country and since Chavez and Castro was
such good buddies,
Chavez gave a lot of money.
Castle,
this was the life raft that we're
supporting Castro's revolution.
Nevertheless,
in 2013,
oil prices collapsed and so did
Venezuela's economy,
and of course we have all that money
drying up and no longer went to Cuba.
Cuba's economy collapsed as well.
Now,
at this time for Dell was already
retired and his brother Raul had taken
the reins of the country.
Raul Castro realized that Cuba was,
once again isolate it and he needed to
change a lot of things or his country
was going to get a whole lot.
Wes gastros Chinese reform,
by the way,
just so I should say now,
if you're enjoying the music in today's
video,
it's by a car and composable.
Rick Spelled Rak.
He's from Columbia.
If you like it,
you will find links to his music in the
description below this video.
All right.
Okay.
Back to 2013,
and Raul Castro and announcing a series
of reforms in Cuba.
The first reform was the legalization of
something called the Quintet Easter's.
This is what we would call a free zone,
and this meant for the first time it
Cubans could start small businesses.
There would still be a lot of
restrictions.
For example,
they still couldn't hire anybody and
they could only start a business.
That was one of the types allowed by the
government.
However,
in the three years since these became
legal,
these freelances of grains and
represents 10 percent of the Cuban
workforce,
it'd be tuition before people were
afraid of doing anything private because
government will take it away from that,
but now the government trusts,
they went the protesters because they
are the future.
Do hold on a moment because there is
more.
In fact,
Raul Castro seems to be following the
Chinese Communist Party's playbook,
which by the way is going to be the
topic of another video which we're going
to be launching very soon actually in a
very dung shopping style.
Raul Castro has created his very own
special economic zone.
This is the so called Marielle
development zone,
so well,
what does this mean?
Well,
in sight,
this his own foreign companies are
allowed to start businesses that were
allowed to hire local people and they
were able to trade with less
restrictions that exist in the rest of
Cuba.
Fife foreign companies to Cuban and I'm
mixed.
One are the first eight companies in the
Maria Development Zone,
which is to become the main economic
goals and through Cuba.
Now you might be wondering how is it
possible that some international
companies such as the Spanish hotel
chain are able to operate in Cuba if
apparently there's a ban on foreign
companies that,
well,
if you're watching this video from
somewhere outside of the United States,
then you might well have traveled to
volunteer at some points.
If that's the case while you were there,
you were probably staying in a best
seller or Emilia hotel.
Both foreign companies,
so these Spanish companies have been
operating in the country since the year
2000,
but the truth is in order to establish
themselves on the islands,
both of these companies to partner with
the Cuban government.
This means that the hotels are owned by
the local governments,
but the hotel chains have a licensed to
operate them and they get a share of the
profits.
So until now it was impossible to start
a company in Cuba unless you were in
partnership with the government.
So the creation of this special economic
zone does show a clear trend or trends
that China's oil in the 19 nineties.
Further to this,
there is a freeing up going on in the
housing markets in just two years,
over 40,000 new homes have been sold in
Cuba.
Now this doesn't exactly mean the Cubans
have private property and the
transactions do you come with a thousand
restrictions,
but it does highlight that there is a
trend going on in the country.
Now.
The most important change in recent
times was Obama's announcement that the
trade embargo between the United States
and Cuba was coming to an end.
The problem is is that still needs to be
passed by the American Congress,
ends with Donald trump being the next
president.
It's very difficult to predict exactly
what's going to happen with that deal,
but controlled by Donald Trump.
The Republican nominee for president
secretly conducted business in communist
Cuba during Fidel Castro's presidency.
Despite strict American trade bands that
made such undertakings illegal,
it's according to interviews with former
trump executives,
internal company records and court
filings.
Yeah.
If trump were to keep the embargo with
Cuba,
that's going to be bad news for
investors who live in the United States.
They would lose out to investors who
come from other countries which don't
have such restrictions.
Britain,
Australia,
Canada free.
Hold on a second because there's still
no guarantee that Cuba is going to
become some sort of free market
paradise,
especially not overnight.
It's not really clear that even if you
were legally allowed to invest in Cuba,
whether that's a good idea or not.
In fact,
there are two potential scenarios that
could play out.
Yeah.
One option is that they followed the
model of track as the vacuum,
which is now two countries,
the Czech Republic and or it's possible
they follow the example of the Ukraine.
Now let's have a look at these two very
different examples.
Czechoslovakia versus Ukraine.
In 1998 tracks of Lakia and the Ukraine
abandons the Communist system,
but there is a really big difference
here.
The checks had a revolution called the
velvet revolution to overthrow their
dictator and the new government led by
this guy on the screen now called fat
Slob Harville.
He sends home the old guard who had been
ruling the country meanwhile over in the
Ukraine,
despite the fact that then got that
political independence,
they kept the same old political elite.
The president's Leonid,
Kraftwerk came from the old communist
party,
but this is not the end of our story.
Just like Ukraine and Czechoslovakia had
plans,
economies where all of the companies
belonged to the government.
The first step in opening up these
economies to the wider world was
privatization,
bus,
and this is really important.
Not all privatizations are created
equally.
Yeah,
took all of their biggest companies and
made a calculation of the economic
value.
Then they divided the economic value of
these countries into bounce sheets.
If you were a checks,
it does,
then you could buy one of these vouchers
for a reasonable price,
something equal to announce a weeks
average salary.
This is why 80 percent of the eligible
population bought a voucher with this
paper in your hands.
You have the rights to buy some shares
in the company in order to help those
who didn't know how to bid for the
shares for the Czech government.
Encouraged the creation of hedge funds,
these hedge funds advised common
citizens on how to invest intelligently.
I check and was able to go to one of
these hedge funds and say I wanted to
get some shares in this company and that
one exception
right
now,
as you can probably imagine that was a
lot of corruption here,
but it also has a really positive
outcome.
It helps the majority of checks to
benefits from the privatization of these
national companies and the proof really
is in the pudding,
yet it's 25 years later and the Czech
Republic is as egalitarian as Germany
and has a quality of life as high as
anywhere else.
Urine
story in Ukraine,
that's a different matter.
Now,
the Ukraine did also sell these
vouchers,
do that citizens.
If you were re Ukrainian citizen,
you could bid for a voucher and
eventually you were able to use this
voucher to buy some shares,
but the reality of the matter is that
the government never got around to
arranging those.
Auctions is only really happens with the
smallest and worst of Ukraine's
companies and the Ukrainians we'll have
to waiting for years.
They had their vouchers in hands,
but they weren't able to do anything
useful with them and unfortunately
during this same time,
Ukraine was also suffering from record
inflation.
When purchased these vouchers would cost
1,500 American dollars,
but some years later they were being
exchanged on the black market for as
little as 10 US dollars.
The average would be sitting at home and
an oligarch would come knocking and he'd
say something like,
Whoa,
what are you going to do with that
voucher?
It's never going to be worth anything to
you,
tell you what you give it to me and I'll
give you some money that you can
actually use and surprise surprise.
Soon enough,
all of the vouchers were in the hands of
the oligarchs and there's no prizes for
guessing here,
but yes,
the oligarchs did have some pretty close
connections to the government.
Then decided to auction off.
All of those companies
come.
Only those companies that were
interesting to the oligarchs were sold,
and that is why Ukraine still has to go
through some privatizations,
but the most important thing to bear in
mind here is that in present day,
Ukraine,
85 percent of the country's wealth is in
the hands of the 50 wealthiest
oligarchs.
The result is no political stability and
they horrific environment for investing.
Oh,
and that's not to mention the whole war
with Russia thing.
So if an investor had bought a property
in Kiev 10 years ago,
they might just be banging their head
against the wall right about now.
All right,
so let's go back to Cuba.
Here we have some things that resemble
Czechoslovakia and we have some things
that resemble Ukraine.
For example,
in the US,
you have 2 million Cubans living.
This represents 20 percent of the entire
Cuban population.
These Cuban Americans have been educated
in a democratic system,
and this could help build good
democratic institutions.
Cuba
does show itself to be the case.
Then Cuba could become a place with rule
of law,
civil rights,
and many opportunities for Cubans to
lift themselves out of poverty.
So now that we've given you the rundown
on Cuba and shared our opinion,
we would love to know yours.
What do you think's going to happen in
Cuba?
Do you think they'll follow the path of
the Czech Republic or the path of
Ukraine?
Please let us know in the comments
below.
Also,
don't forget that we put our brand new
videos every Monday and Thursday,
so don't forget to subscribe to make
sure that you get all of those videos.
Also,
if you enjoyed this video,
please give it a thumbs up below and
I'll see you next time.